Hey guys,
In today's world,
especially in 2024, nothing's changed.
A lot of people continually run after pleasure
so that they can be happy or so they think.
They think they'll be happy.
Because you see, temporary happiness
... pleasure ... is totally different
from eternal joy and peace.
Those are two different things.
And that is why so many people are unhappy today.
You see, it's a vicious cycle, because
the more they want to experience
pleasure, the more they crave it.
And they can't get enough of it and
when they don't get it they are unhappy.
And then they wonder why they
are not happy in life anymore.
Just look at the world.
You see most young people cannot even go through
the day without putting earphones into their ears
and listen to music to try and make their normal
daily activities, their reality, better.
And then when they get back home, people
drink to feel better.
To feel pleasure.
Or they use drugs and most of us today, we need
to have our phone in hand to scroll down social
media to be constantly entertained.
Are you one of those people who
cannot enjoy the normal world, the
natural world around you anymore?
You need to be constantly entertained
because you're addicted to pleasure?
Is that you?
Is that what you have become?
And yes there is good pleasure and there is bad
pleasure, but none of them can give you lasting
peace and joy, which is what you really want.
And it is unfortunate but that is also why so
many Christians today do not read their Bibles
anymore, because they're addicted to pleasure.
They get back home and they see the
Bible there, but they just put it on
the side because they just want to have pleasure.
So they choose their hobbies or they sit down and
watch a TV series or movie.
Sometimes worldly things.
And they don't grow in their faith
and they wonder why they are unhappy.
The Spirit is willing always.
God wants us to connect with Him
but you see, the flesh is the problem.
Addicted to pleasure, it is weak.
[Proverbs 21:17]
And you know, young people especially, my
heart goes out to young people today because
the programs - entertainment - and things we
heard in the media were so different than today.
Today - everywhere you look - there's temptation.
Doesn't matter what you do, or where you go,
it's just temptation everywhere.
So the question is then, is it possible for
young people today to overcome temptation?
No, it is not.
Not by yourself.
It is impossible.
But through Christ, we can do all things.
Paul said to the young Timothy in 2 Timothy 2:22:
[2 Timothy 2:22]
So he doesn't say look at temptation, go a little
bit closer, investigate it, think about it,
is it good, or not.
Walk around it.
No.
He says flee youthful passions.
And then what?
Pursue righteousness, faith, love, and peace.
And pursue God with all your heart.
With a pure heart.
[1 Corinthians 10:13]
You see, we have no excuses.
Too many Christians today
have excuses all the time.
But God says that He will not let
us be tempted beyond our ability.
And he will provide a way of
escape so we have no excuses.
We need to trust God and resist the cookie
house of the devil with all the temptations.
It's only there to lure you
away from the light, from God.
And one of the worst temptations there is,
for especially men, is sexual temptation.
[1 Corinthians 6:18-20]
Your body is the temple of God.
It is Holy and it is not yours anymore.
So do not use it for sexual sin.
[1 Thessalonians 4:4]
Stay away from the things that the natural
person yearns for, the sinful worldly pleasures.
Because you are not from this world.
You are born from above, from God.
You have His spirit in you.
And He cries out, Abba,
Father, you're a new creation
if you are indeed God's child.
So let your sinful desires of pleasure
die and cling to your spiritual desires.
[Colossians 3:5]
You need to be very careful
of the things that give you
too much pleasure because before you
know it, you can get addicted to it.
And if that happens, you start
to put it in front of God.
So God is not the priority of your life anymore.
And then you will never have true joy and peace,
because that comes only from God.
He is the God of peace.
[John 14: 27]
Earthly pleasure is all temporary and what
would it help you if you gain the whole world.
Everything that your sinful heart desires?
If you get it, if you experience it, and then
you die and lose your soul for all eternity,
teeth gnashing in hell because of regret.
Eternity is a very long time.
You know, there was one man in
the Bible who had every pleasure known to man.
Everything that he could have under the sun,
he had it.
His name is Solomon.
He had 600 wives and 300 concubines.
That's sexual pleasure.
He had riches.
The best clothing, the best food, the
best wine, the best of everything under the sun.
He had everything his heart could desire.
And what did he say at the end of his life?
He said in Ecclesiastes 1:
[Ecclesiastes 1:2]
How many of you can honestly say that your
pleasures give you eternal joy that never stops?
And who of you are crying on the
inside while you smile on the outside?
With the mask you put on in front of others?
Many of you know exactly what I'm talking about.
Deep inside of you there's pain.
Sometimes you think about it.
Sometimes you try to ignore it because it's
too tough for you to handle, to deal with.
And the uncomfortable questions.
You don't want to linger on it - where
do you come from, what will happen to
you when you die, what is your purpose.
Something is missing in your life and you know it.
The peace and joy that you've
always been searching for.
You thought the new job would do it.
Your new relationships.
Your new car, new clothes,
new this and new that.
But still,
that true pure joy and peace is missing.
There is something missing in your life.
So let me ask you - do you know God?
Because it is only He that can give it to you.
Even those of you who are very
religious, but do not have a
personal relationship with Christ are empty.
Because works religion, without true faith,
a true encounter and a relationship
with Christ, means absolutely nothing.
And it will also not save your soul.
In Him, you not only find eternal life,
but also the right kind of pleasures.
And through the Holy Spirit,
you always continually experience true joy
and peace, even in trials and tribulations.
And even for me, I was looking
for that in all the wrong places.
I drank a lot.
I went after girls.
I made a lot of money.
Nothing could give it to me.
But then I found God and I found what
I was looking for and I never knew it
and this peace that is impossible to find in
this world with temporary things - material
things - you can only find it in Christ Himself.
And when you find it you will realize that it
almost doesn't make any sense.
It surpasses all understanding.
How are you able to have
this continual peace and joy?
After surrendering to Jesus
Christ as Lord and Savior?
It is because this peace is
supernaturally produced by God Himself.
It comes from Him.
You cannot find it in sex,
money, your career, or even your family.
You cannot find it in any material
temporary thing.
Only in God.
[Psalm 16:11]
[Isaiah 26:3]
If you say you're a Christian, and
you don't have this peace and joy,
let me ask you, have you lost your first
love because of temporary pleasure?
There's things in your life that
you're putting in front of God?
If that's the case, how is
that working out for you?
You repeat the same thing day after
day, and unbelievers do the same thing.
They work only for the weekend, to drink and
get drunk, and then, they work in the week
without peace and joy again.
And they do that just to be
able to have the weekend again.
To drink and get drunk, and a cycle
repeats itself over and over until they die.
The natural person just works to have pleasure.
Running, chasing after pleasure
and cannot find eternal peace.
Many just change alcohol with porn,
drugs, careers, relationships, and other
things.
The world and
the sugar of this world will bring you cancer.
And the devil uses it to try and lure as many
people as possible with him into hell.
He gives them pleasure.
He makes this worldly prison cell - this
amazing place - the candy store that you
can just do and gratify your sinful flesh
with everything that your heart desires.
And at the end, you'll lose
your soul for all eternity.
Solomon said:
Vanity of vanities.
It is all vanity.
Everything he owned means nothing.
He died and it means nothing.
Everything you own means nothing.
When you die it means nothing.
So it is better to live for God,
and have a little, than have everything that
brings you into the fiery flames of hell.
[Psalm 37:16]
Oh taste and see that the Lord is good.
When you finally live for Him,
you realize He is all you need.
Because you think that you're
going to have a little and you have to sacrifice
your fleshly desires, but you gain so much more.
Not just eternal life, but also that joy and peace
and also everything you need to accomplish God's
purpose and plan for your life.
He will help you.
He will give it to you.
You gain a father.
You become His child.
The God of the universe is your father.
And then He even gives you all spiritual
blessings while you are on this temporary
world and that far outweighs any
earthly sinful pleasure or possession.
[Ephesians 1:3]
If you still lack that peace, then
draw closer to God with everything
that is in you.
Don't waste time.
[James 4:8]
Come back to God if you've been
distracted by the pleasures of this world.
Go to God today.
Go into your room, close the
door and make your relationship right with God.
And then you will have peace and joy again.
[Romans 14:17]
If you are a Christian but you can't seem to
stop worrying and have anxiety and you don't have
that full, that complete peace and joy in Christ,
then you might not have fully surrendered to God.
So please watch this video
here and it will help you.
Subscribe and always remember, life is short.
So don't waste yours.
Bye.